Silicon Valley is now under pressure to
deal with the complaints about sexual
harassment data security user safety and
privacy one venture capitalist firm
hopes to turn the tide of public opinion
by investing in new tech companies that
aim to solve the world's hardest
problems Chama Paulo Hypatia is founder
and CEO of social capital it's a two and
a half billion dollar venture capital
firm that invests in health care
education and financial services the
company's portfolio includes includes
file-share company box business
application slack and online survey
company Survey Monkey palapa Tia was
Facebook's vice president for user
growth before starting social capital
seven years ago good morning thanks for
being with us thanks for so the question
is on issues like healthcare and climate
change is that there is some special
approach that venture capitalists have
or is it that you're just getting
engaged at all instead of just trying to
make money creating these alloys yeah
it's it's very much the latter I mean I
think what's happened in the last
probably 10 years is particularly young
people has lost faith in the
institutions that were supposed to be
solving these problems and so you know
when I took a step back at Facebook I
had a decision to make which was to
continue to stay there and I had a lot
of success there or to take a lot of
those financial gains and reallocate
them to these kinds of problems and say
well if the EPA is not going to do
something around climate what can
private citizens and what can
technologists do to solve them if you
know for example Health and Human
Services can't make a lot of progress on
cancer or diabetes or asthma in you know
middle America or low-income communities
what can we do using software and
technology and that's what we've done it
we've had a lot of success to use a bad
phrase maybe but are you trying to hack
government or just go around it neither
I would just say that at the end of the
day you know look America is driven by
this sort of industrial resolve and this
sort of entrepreneurialism where if
things aren't solved private citizens
tend to be able to do a good job and the
reality is for-profit businesses tend to
be the best way to solve these problems
because they create enduring companies
right and so at the end of the day if we
can put a dent in cancer or put a dent
in climate and leave these companies in
a state where they will live past our
generation for our kids and our kids
kids I think that's a fantastic formula
your firm uses artificial intelligence
right to decide what to invest in
describe how that works
you know I think we're in a world now
where there is so much complexity things
change constantly right you'll have a
company that's successful today and
tomorrow could get disrupted and so what
we did was we took a step back and said
in that kind of a model we have to be
really responsible when we invest and
the best way to do that is to have
computers help people like myself make
better decisions and so that's how we do
it we use computers and software to help
analyze a lot of data inside of a
company so that we don't miss things our
viewers are familiar with you because of
some of the warnings you've raised about
Facebook and social media being
addictive one your kids are not allowed
to have any screen time yeah how old are
your children nine seventy five do they
like you how does that work in your
house especially because this is your
this is definitely your wheelhouse you
know why did you do that and why did you
it is critical for me to do my part in
raising morally and ethically aware
children I want children who can make
eye contact I want children who know how
to resolve conflicts with their peers I
want children who understand the
dynamics of interpersonal relationships
that are physical and tactile I do not
want children that only know how to
interface with the world through a
screen okay so here's the question slack
yeah shouldn't we be down the hall
talking to each other instead of
slacking with each other so when you are
18 19 20 35 45 and you're doing work and
you want to efficiently do work in an
organization and you want to be in an
organization that doesn't have office
politics slack is a fantastic tool yeah
but when you are 9 10 12 13 14 and
you're developing your sense of self my
perspective is you should be looking at
people in the eye you should be dealing
with them in real life you should be
getting a job you should be outside
playing you should be learning how the
real world works oh that sounds so good
but I want to go back to your kids for a
second yeah how are they going to
navigate the world when we live in
something that is so that everybody is
so technology focused and so attached to
the technology well that's going to
navigate I mean we all have smartphones
today yeah how long did it really take
us to learn well frankly smartphones
only existed for the last decade
right did we all have computers when we
were growing up I did not I didn't need
right and I learned how to master a lot
of what Silicon Valley has to offer in
the last 15 years so the point is adults
when they are trained are capable of
many things so I suspect that my
children at some point will learn how to
use these devices and they'll be okay
the CEO of Salesforce so we all know
Marc Benioff Margaritaville has said
that social media is so addictive that
it should be regulated as the former
head of Facebook's user growth do you
agree with that I don't think it should
be regulated in the construct of how
people use it but I think what's really
important is to do two things number one
all these social media sites now allow
us to confuse truth in popularity that
has to be fixed so true because every
normal citizen has a right to know what
is factual versus what is amplified by
good actors or bad actors that's the
first thing and then the second thing is
every single citizen of every single
country of the world has a right to
understand what data are they giving and
what are they getting happens so in that
construct there's probably some
regulatory framework that makes them how
does the regulatory framework deal with
the first piece though cuz government
getting involved in that it's just gonna
be a mess it's unclear to me but I think
what it's probably going to do is going
to result in a refactoring of how
business models work on the Internet
listen the reality is for the last 20
years we've been living in a utopia we
all get things for free and we pay
nothing for them right now if you for
example bought a car and you were just
given the car meaning it cost nothing
and then the seatbelts didn't work and
the airbags didn't deploy you'd have no
recourse because the car manufacturer
would say well hold on a second I gave
you a free car yes right if you bought
milk you can expect it to be pasteurized
if you're given milk and it makes you
sick you have no recourse so similarly
on the internet we have to ask ourselves
if you are not paying for something you
are probably part of the product not the
consumer or customer who has rights by
buying a product right Wow
really good to see ya love Expedia
thanks for being here with one of the
coolest names in the business of Oz Paul
yep
you go see I told you it was cool